diesen städtischen weg im nordrhein
westfälischen solingen reinigt jochen
schaaf seit jahren weil die kehrmaschine
hier nicht rein fährt sieht er es als
seine bürgerpflicht an den job zu machen
doch vor wenigen tagen bekommt er ein
schreiben schaaf soll rund 900 euro für
die reinigung des weges an die stadt
zahlen dem er tag für tag sauber macht
sie wollten vier jahre rückwärts eine
reinigungs gebühr für diesen abschnitt
hier neben meinem grundstück den sie
aber nie gereinigt haben dafür wollten
sie der 900 euro haben haben in dem
brief auch gleich geschrieben dass sie
in zukunft hier auch nicht reinigen
werden auch die passanten können nicht
glauben dass jochen schaaf für seinen
freiwilligen reinigungsdienst nun auch
noch zur kasse gebeten wird
ja also eigentlich ist es echt ne
unverschämtheit er sorgt für ordnung und
soll denn dafür bestraft werden und soll
dafür bezahlt werden das ist auch dass
es so hirnrissig
also es kann von gerechtigkeit keine
rede sein
vor dem haus fährt die städtische
kehrmaschine dafür zahlt scharf
selbstverständlich da das fahrzeug hier
aber nicht wenden kann wird auch nicht
gereinigt zahlen soll anwohner scharf
aber trotzdem so die stadt noch
vergangene woche wenn eine straße
gereinigt wird dann heißt es ja nicht
dass jeder quadratmeter der straße
gereinigt wird es gibt da so ein
hübsches satz vom ovg bestimmte
unvollkommenheiten der nicht reinigung
sind situations gegeben hinzunehmen
also nichts tun und trotzdem abkassieren
jochen schaaf ist stinksauer
das finde ich wirklich eine frechheit
man verlangt geld und will die leistung
dafür nicht erbringen
das geht mal gar nicht nachdem sich der
länderspiegel einschaltet erhält herr
schaaf plötzlich post vom amt die stadt
solingen hat nicht etwa eingesehen dass
sie fürs nichtstun auch nicht einfach
passieren kann nein sie darf laut ihrer
eigenen satzung für diese art von
verbindungsweg gar keine gebühren
verlangen
der chef der technischen betriebe zeigt
sich einsichtig
wir werden jetzt diesem fall und auch
vergleichbare weitere fälle es gibt in
der direkten umgebung auch zwei weitere
fälle genauso einstufen und in diesem
speziellen fall keine gebühren
veranlagung durchführen für sein
fleißiges kehren muss er scharf also
nicht auch noch löhnen eigentlich eine
selbstverständlichkeit
ich bin sehr froh damit sie das hier
auch bewiesen werden konnte dass wenn
der bürger sich entsprechend kundig
macht er auch gelegentlich die stadt
davon überzeugen kann dass die stadt
male unrecht ist
und so macht jochen schaaf weiter für
die stadt und seine mitbürger natürlich
gebührenfrei